- Le jour des Morts n'aura
lieu que mardi, mais déjà,
les squelettes et les crânes
géants se multiplient
dans les rues de Mexico, des
oeuvres remplies de couleurs,
mais non dénuées de tristesse.
Puisque après une année
de pandémie très difficile
au Mexique, il y a beaucoup
de morts à honorer.
"En souvenir de ceux qui
sont partis, mais qui restent
dans nos coeurs", peut-on lire
sur ce mur. Cet autel est
un mémorial en l'honneur
des victimes de la COVID-19.
"Toutes les familles qui ont
perdu un être cher pendant
la pandémie peuvent venir
dire au revoir à leur façon."
Les 14 mètres du monument
commémoratif sont décorés
avec des coeurs en argent,
qui symbolisent les victimes.
Selva Pérez tenait
à s'y recueillir.
En 2020, elle a perdu
sa grand-mère, son oncle
et son grand-oncle,
avec qui elle habitait.
En fait, la moitié des gens sous
son toit sont morts de la COVID.
Elle n'est pas seule
à venir pleurer ses morts.
Cet homme, lui, a apporté
la photo de son beau-frère
et de sa belle-soeur
décédés ce printemps.
Signe que la situation
s'améliore malgré tout,
les restrictions sont
plus souples cette année
et permettent de se réunir
en plus grand nombre.
"Cette fois-ci, en plus
d'honorer les morts, promet
cette femme, nous allons
célébrer la vie de ceux
qui ont survécu à la maladie."
C'est que le Mexique commence
tranquillement à remonter
la pente; les infections sont
en baisse, tout comme les décès,
et plus de 80 % des adultes
ont reçu au moins
une dose de vacccin.